anthony mackie and i are high in the
dolomite mountains of italy
doing a great job anthony well done
we're using an old hemp rope
just like soldiers would use in world
war one to descend the sheer rock face
it's about now i reckon anthony's
wishing he had his falcon wings
at his beck and cool
how you doing anthony
i'm good you're getting there you're
like halfway now
oh man this is a straight wall
there's no footing on this wall keep
going
i've still got you on this line so
you're good
okay come on come on
oh come on there's nothing here bear
okay do you want me to come down here
let me come and join you no i do not
want you on this rope with me
okay last bit walk it out climb it down
come on anthony come on just gotta make
it to right there
right there come on anthony come on
great job anthony smashed it
i hate you bear okay here we go
that was really scary when i first went
over the wall
i thought i was gonna fall smashing
through the rocks
then i kind of just wanted to tuck into
a ball
and roll down that cavern and smash into
the rocks
but i really wanted to do it so my sons
could see me doing something crazy
and i made it down get it
good job here anthony oh that's more
it's more awkward than it looks isn't it
maybe we're going to just tuck down on
the edge here okay
i never want to do that again no you
won't ever have to do that again
that was clearly tough for anthony and
underneath the fatigue
i can tell that he's so proud of himself
for making it down the mountain
let's take two minutes have a little
drink
so yeah a little recovery yeah but good
job
that was intense
[Music]
you